miami book fair international and the
weekend of december 6 we'll see all
those
awesome interviews that we
have not had a chance to show you today
we're here for two two full days live
today for nine hours with our cameras
and uh yesterday all day taping events
for you so you can get a taste of the
many authors both local and national who
have been here speaking to
more than 500 000 people over the past
week who attend the miami book fair
international joining us right now on
our c-span school bus which is serving
as our studio for the book fair is alina
fernandes who is the author of castro's
daughter she herself is castro's
daughter and she's written a book about
her childhood experiences thank you for
being here thank you this is your first
book why did you want to tell the story
why well i think cuba is still a mystery
you know
even for american people cuba is a
victim of a big propaganda machinery so
just to help communication to let you
know why we are here invading maybe the
place right
and uh why do we got here
what has been living in a country like
that for 40 years on the under an
unfinished revolution just to make us
know a little better and i use my person
for i think as a measure of honesty
on the book but it's more a social story
and
it's full of humor and anecdotes and
daily life when is the last time you set
foot on cuban soil
five years ago actually i escaped from
the country the 19th december 1993.
and was it a particular frustration for
cuban leadership that you would leave
because you were so well known
i don't know if i was well known or not
i had the duty to get my daughter out of
there
but was did you hear any reactions after
the fact of
people who um were particularly upset
that you left the country
let's see i'm just wondering about the
politics of you leaving somebody's
looking out yes i know we were in our
our studio here and getting lots of
attention but but let's go back to your
story with you leaving
um because your book chronicles the fact
that people were aware of who you were
yes was the government particularly
upset that you i think i think maybe yes
but it not only happened to me any
defector from there gets a lot of
attention and
you know
trades sometimes
what is it what is life like for you now
because your book ends the day that you
leave i think i like to escape from
places now
well i've been moving around i stayed
two years in georgia two years in new
york now i'm staying in spain it's like
that and i really enjoyed the the the
freedom of movement is something big for
me why do you move so much
i like it i like it i was obliged to
stay 38 years in cuba
like everybody else there too
and i think there's a big discovery
we are going to open up our telephone
lines and if you would like to
participate in this discussion we have a
book now to talk about it but over the
years the whole uh aspect of cuban
american policy is something we've
talked about a great deal as it's been
debated in washington and the floor of
congress so if you'd like to join in the
discussion and and lend your point of
view to this you are most welcome if
you'd like to learn more about alina
fernandez and her book and how she wrote
it please do join us as well
202-624-1111 for those of you in the
eastern half of the united states 202
624 1115 if you're watching in the
western half of the united states well
what was it like to write a book
it's a very neurological experience
really i isolate myself for a few months
i mean at least six
uh went away two
didn't have phone
and wrote at night so
and it's not the job i can recommend and
you wrote in your native language
spanish yes correct this is the book as
it was first published and it was
published in spanish translate the name
of it for us please
oh jesus i'm unable to do that there's
something
like memory of
rebellious castro's daughter or
something rebellious yes i'm unable to
to say that in spanish either so and
when it came out in the english version
the rebel was gone
hopefully i
i did my best to get that for out it's
an exiles memoir of cuba why did you
want it out
because
that's not the name you give to the book
that's name your publisher gives to the
book and still
is very uncomfortable for a person to
say my book is called a memoir of the
rebellious whatever it's just ridiculous
when was this photograph taken when i
was 16.
very different photograph on the front
of this book that's it this one is did
when it's dark you know i think that
people will see this cover and the name
and they will they will think oh
i know what i will find down there and
that's not the intention it's a very
happy book at the end it's hopeful
and
it has all the
when you can't find yourself crying or
laughing because it goes to extremes can
be happy and dramatic
and it's not like that that seems to be
like a black stain you see like a black
story it's not that at all i think that
cuban we are very very happy
people so for you the english language
version cover better depicts what you
think the story is i think this and i
had the best translations
did the book change at all in
translation i think it does a lot
it's totally different
was anything intentionally changed did
you take sections out i i did
you know because i feel that my family
felt hurt somehow and i took some pieces
out too to make it more understandable
to the
to the american people because uh if you
come from cuba or even from latin
america you can relate to what i'm
saying
but if you just don't it's too difficult
so we we fix that
we're going to it's a lot out take some
calls from our audience and then come
back and dig into more of the story you
have to tell our first call for you is
from deerfield beach florida welcome to
our discussion
uh good afternoon yes sir i come from
trinidad in the caribbean
and we have a different uh view well i
wouldn't say we but i do of uh
cidel
to his daughter i say your father has
three major achievements
he has the lowest birth rate in the
latin america
cuba's birth rate is 13.6 per thousand
secondly cuba does not need the united
states your father can get all the
investment he needs from europe and
canada
and thirdly he kicked out the mafia that
had corrupted cuba
and gave cuba its protestant reformation
let me stop you for one second are you
hearing the caller yes you've heard the
questions yes
i don't understand the question i think
he has something to say that he deeply
believes he said that he believes that
fidel castro has had three major
achievements one which he listed as the
lowest birth rate
uh in in this area of the world
birth rate yes fewest babies born so
well yeah i mean of course it has made
some accomplishments and
i'm not speaking about what he fell on
and i'm speaking out everything it's a
very personal story you shouldn't expect
to find hate against fidel or a story
about fidel it's a biography
so let's spend a minute before we take
our next call and have you uh tell us a
little bit about your story you were one
of how many children i think that uh
as i know we are eight
and who is your mother
nathi rewelda and can you tell us what
her relationship was to fidel castro uh
i think they had a great romance uh on
the 50s
from maybe 52 to
59
and
they exchanged a lot of lovely letters
which i show
by itself in the book
and
it was i think at the beginning a very
romantic and for my mother at least the
most important relationship she ever had
but they never married no never married
when i was born my my mother was married
to somebody else fidel castro did marry
and and had other children in within the
bounds of marriage i think afterwards he
did but i don't get into details on that
you know because it's social his
personal life that i only uh describe
how his relationship was with me
when did you learn that fidel castro was
your father i was told that when i was
10 years old and can you remember being
surprised no i don't think so because at
that time he was the only male presence
at home so
i kind of felt released as my father dr
fernandez the person who gave me of
course my name
had been trained as traitor and guzano
you know the people who left the regime
with trade like that from the beginning
i felt when i was 10 years old that at
least i i was
rid of that stigma
you see because you have to say down
sign down in school that you have some
guzano parents and it was very sad
what does that expression mean because i
know it's warm luzano
they trade
as gusanos the people who are leaving
the country or dislike the regime and
or traitors you see let's take some more
calls and then we'll come back and learn
a little bit about what your life was
like on the island dallas texas you're
on the air for alina fernandez yes this
is dr gray i'm a pastor here in dallas
and i'm impressed with the program and
i'm always impressed with the way you
conduct it
uh my question for alina is
is there anything that she can do to
help normalize
relations with the united states
many of us here in the united states
would love to go to cuba
we've read history of cuba
and we would like for cuba and america
to be on friendly terms
is she doing anything or can she do
anything
to help normalize that
i always try to do my best i always try
to do my best for my fellow peoples here
and for my fellow fellow peoples they
are now in spain i'm helping on a
non-profit organization to send
medicines i don't know what else i can
do i think that it's not the american
government who stopped the normalization
is the cuban government who does you see
by some violent answers sometimes
i would like to see that change too
since you have left the soviet union has
collapsed and
we have learned that the patronage of
the soviet union of course ended for
cuba have you learned what has happened
to life for the citizens there in those
in these years but of course everything
disappeared we used to receive
more than 200 million monthly from
from the russians
and definitively everything collapsed
and whatever is being done or not done
down in cuba and the inside on the
economical side
was so evident at that time and that's
the way we kept going but you already
described in your book a life with very
few supplies
how how could it have it gone from this
description with virtually nothing for
families to less than that
well as you get more tourism there
people are still able to to get some
dollars to live but now let me say that
in cuba you have families living on a
four dollars salary monthly
so it's
is undescriptible i mean it's it's such
a difficult situation to to to describe
to the american people
that that's why i'm so happy the book is
being translated
west palm beach florida is next you're
on for alina fernandez
thank you
my name is john sanchez uh i'm just glad
to see you alina on tv the last time i
saw you was five or six years ago
and uh the impression i received from
that moment it was a a lot of pain and
you have a lot of stress
i was glad today
to see the new face you look so
beautiful and uh thank you full of life
i'm glad for that i hope your daughter
is doing well
i am not q1 but
i understand how the situation is over
there
and how tough it is i have a question
yes if you got the chance
to go back to cuba what would you like
to do first
i think i would like to work in uh in
education
because we we have children
that have lost their parents trying to
get across the sea to get them a better
life
we have children who come from this
totally terrific regime so i think that
children are the more important thing to
rebuild and help how old is your
daughter she's 20. and how old was she
when she left cuba 16.
have you had much chance
to compare her education
uh from the time she left to what she
had before well at the time she left
that that's one of the reason i escaped
i had to take her out from school
because
riding a bicycle every day that you can
lost because there is no transportation
so anybody could kill you in order to
get your bicycle then the school was
empty teachers
were not going because they had to ride
their bicycles too so the situation was
all collapsed for me and at the time i
left i i had the idea that it will get
to an end very soon but we still are
surviving you see now she's getting an
education here and it's a big difference
once she got here she went to school and
she had already two years college
for me is a success
can you tell us how the people of cuba
really feel about fidel castro at this
point i don't know i think that feelings
are so various
i know
that people want him to go i know that
people hate him i know people who are
still patient i know people who still
wait for him to fix
their daily basis
it's very different and what are your
own feelings
i think that nothing will change until
he goes away
do you have any affection for him as a
father
not now you have to establish a
difference between what
your
feeling of justice here is and
i am a cuban woman in exile that's what
i am
next call is from san diego you're on
the air thank you i'm interested in
hearing what syndra fernandez thinks
about
the blockade the effect it's having in
cuba
the effect it's having in the u.s and
any
idea why the thing has gone on longer
than any other blockade we've ever held
yes well uh
i gotta say something we had that
blockade in spite of which one cuban has
been exporting wars all over the world
so you see we had made an angola war for
seven years with the presence of 150 000
cuban soldiers
we've been involved in both nowhere
actually we almost made the nicaragua
war the salvador war the guatemala war
we've been involved in all the
guerrillas building airports all over
the world and nothing has been done in
cuba i think that the reason of the
cuban result now
is not the blockade
because in spite of that blockade we've
been able to export war
still is
the cuban regime way of leading
next is a call from new york city
hi this is julie casanova i'm in new
york um
do you find that it's very difficult to
human to communicate
the
type of lifestyle one
a cuban family undergoes
in a common day
in cuba
yes i i found it's very difficult i
think that that's why i wrote the book
uh to to make american people able to
understand what's going on there on the
revolution that never ends
i wonder what
french will do with robespierre there
for 40 years
could you and i know you spent many
pages but for people who
might wonder what they would find could
you tell us
for example what it's just like finding
housing
is impossible because nothing is being
built from
1965 or 69 maybe when they finish by
doing those
multi-family buildings nothing else has
been done
and what condition is the house what
happened is that you you you finally
save four generations under the same
roof which is mostly what had happened
to to me so
you have the grandma deciding what do
you have to feed your husband
with
and it makes things very difficult and
how about food supplies
well now
[Music]
there is a dollar
social class and the pace of social
class
and
it's been two years now i think that
dollar is legal and you can always only
buy
your food and supplies in dollars so
there is a part of the society which is
doing you know surviving and another
part is really in poverty and misery is
it allowable
either by the the u.s government or by
the cuban government for exiles to send
money back to cuba
we always manage to do that in fact we
are maintaining
three quarters of whatever gets into the
country dollar speaking three quarters
of what comes into the country is comes
from cuban exiles yes
and do you know how
the american government feels about that
in essence it's allowing the society to
continue
i don't think they can do anything we
will always find a way to to do it
next calls from hartford connecticut
hi elena hello nice talking to you
i have a question because in some ways
well i wasn't that close to castro or
anything like that
but
i went through the same process and i
would like to know what really making
you
made your mind and take the hard
decision to leave cuba because i really
think that at some moment that was a
really hard decision for you
i hear
that you have to waste so
you lost some way
um try to fake some kind of identity to
leave cuba
um
i would like to get your feedback from
that thank you were you a cuban as well
yes i am in cuba as well i was member of
the army and i left cuba three years ago
three years ago can you tell us briefly
how you were able to leave
well um
let me see what i can say on tv but
basically
i was in jail
for political reasons i was
a captain and a medical captain in the
army
and
somehow i get the political refugee
condition from the usa government
took me two years to leave cuba i was
two years sitting in my house
waiting for a miracle
i know how she may fell at that time
because i had the same experience
thank you for your call i've seen you
you're you have been as courageous or
you call me sir you know
and congratulations because you're here
safe now
uh of course i had to escape too and
that's what
we say that in cuba down there they have
10 10
million prisoners because nobody's
allowed to leave the country because
you're only allowed when you want to
create a crisis here in the united
states like it happened almost three
years ago with the 200 000 rafters
because you're shocked if you try to
leave the country in a raft by the
border police
and that's the way it is
when that caller is was concerned about
what he could say on television
what is the level of danger for people
who may have relatives who have escaped
who have relatives back on the island
well they can lose their jobs or they
can be somehow repressed and it's some
kind of psychological torture you know
people
at the beginning they try to make us a
shame from having relatives living in
the united states now is impossible
because everybody has
one relative almost everybody has
one relative living outside the country
next call for alina fernandez is from
springfield missouri you're on the air
uh yeah i wanted to know what she
thought about the chilean dictator being
taken into custody in england and what
would she think if if her father was if
he was
similarly visiting the country and
he was taken into custody
and he tried
well
we have a group of cuban exile that had
presented in the spanish court a case
against castro too and it wasn't
accepted but there is no doubt about
that every dictatoring earth will have
thousands of victims and we still don't
know how many victims have made down in
angola down in nicaragua down in el
salvador
and we don't know how many people we
lost trying to get across the sea
we don't know how many soldiers we had
lost in angola too by the cuban side
it's it's a very mysterious situation
yet
in addition to the cuban population here
in the miami south florida area where
else in the united states are there
large cuban populations i think that we
have some in new jersey we are all over
but i think the miami is the big
what um i know you're just going on book
tour with us but uh what what acceptance
level uh do people uh
criticize you uh are they happy to have
you here what's your acceptance i am
always being a controversial person so
if i found myself without any critic i
feel very bad
why is that
because if
if
you're doing something you need people
with you and you need people against you
there is no way out without controversy
and i'm not a singer or a diva somehow
i'm just a writer and i'm just i'm just
trying to break a little bit
that enormous propaganda
machinery they have made over my country
and my people
this is the book we're talking about
it's castro's daughter as published in
its english version it's saint martin's
press and its retail price is 23.95
published in october of this year and if
you have members of your family who are
spanish readers there is a version of it
as well in spanish the original version
of the book let's take our next call for
alina fernandez it's from athens georgia
alina i want to congratulate you for
your book i read it in spanish and i'm
very happy that it's been translated in
english
because your story has to be read by the
whole world in order to understand
the destruction of the cuban revolution
they have destroyed all the civil
religious
family institutions that existed in cuba
the other thing that we don't have to
understand
is that the united states government has
tried on many occasions to normalize
relations with cuba and at every single
juncture the cuban government has
has created obstacles and sabotage that
they did it in 1970s when they sent
troops to africa and they did it in 1996
when they killed four
americans three americans and one
one resident or in international waters
the cuban government right now sends
drugs into the united states has
biological and chemical weapons ready
and they're mass destructive
they have killed over 35 u.s citizens in
the last 40 years
they continue to undermine the united
states national security interest they
have the largest spy satellite listening
station in lourdes cuba that can listen
to this telephone conversation
and all others
my question to you is uh what do you
think
i think you're totally right and i agree
with you in every point you have
announced
today is the anniversary of the kennedy
assassination yes november 22nd you
write in your book about having some
awareness of john kennedy as a child yes
can you tell me how you viewed him what
you knew of him well uh you're always
been trying to be ridiculous to be you
know to be shown as a ridiculous uh
fellows and that's when the way kennedy
looked to me i was eight years old he
was always showing his wars pictures and
he was supposed to be the
great enemy
so
when he was shot
we
we were supposed to to become very happy
and in school
we had ordered some activities
to
you know to clap for the fact that he
was shot you also write of being aware
of what is known in this country is the
cuban missile crisis yes what was it
like for you there as a child
it's history history i mean historical
reactions and fidel trying to make
people convinced that they were in the
center of a
world crisis and they were managing
russians and both americans too
but we've always been brainwashed you
know
springfield virginia you're next in our
discussion uh yes hi um first of all i
was wondering uh this group that filed
this
this document in spain i believe that's
the cuban american national foundation
and um there's been a lot of evidence
recently of their terrorist activities
from u.s shores
and they're also they've uh contra made
about four million dollars in campaign
contributions i was wondering if alina
is affiliated with these organizations
or has had any experience with them
no i'm not i'm really not you know and
at the same time i know i know that
there is a lot of victims that no one of
them you see they will always find my
support but i don't belong to any
organization
in the exile
next is lincoln nebraska
good afternoon i've got a two-part
question please
one
not assassination but everybody dies
sometime after fidel dies
his brother is i think is still planning
on taking over
are there many changes
anticipated
uh and is there any chance of
normalization after that place happens
or is that going to be the very same
continuation as fattel's policies
and what's your second you said two
parts okay and the second part is is
there any way to visit
i'm in nebraska of course u.s citizen
okay is there any way to visit cuba for
example going to canada and traveling
out of canada or some other arrangements
why do you want to go
i would like to see it very much
thank you
i don't think there is any other
accommodation you got to go to mexico or
santo domingo or
that's as you said it's difficult
and the first question was the first one
we'll take
castro rahul castro will take cover i
don't think so i think that
humanly and sociological speaking there
is no more communism in the rest of the
planet so we are going to go
straight to democracy
you're sure of that i i'm sure of that i
want to go back to a comment you made
about people being killed for their
bicycles what is crime like
crime is becoming so awful you know
because you can get killed inside your
house in order to get your tv
that's the way it is and is that
different from when you were a child
yes and what what caused the change
i think that the shame is being caused
because the
what are we now you see is
what have we been uh obligated to do
like going
everywhere else in the world to to kill
two as an army as an international army
we've been teach that internationalism
is good
so i don't know what had happened to in
the in the moral side
and uh people had become like that and
and the worst thing and the thing that
worries is
that those are young people
next call is from jersey city you're on
the air
yeah good afternoon
my name is
here before and i'm come back for cuba
two weeks ago
and i wanted to ask you how about a
human right in cuba and the chitra
diet for medicine food in the old people
prices are all over the cheetah face and
the people walking the street like a
robot
what they have to say about that and
your father and one more question how
many times you talk to your father in
the time you'll be in usa capo let's
america and keep strong for the people
cuba he started broke
people died for hunk
i see that my eyes my family my neighbor
is all destroyed
this even a little dog walking the
street like
you know how the same way he goes why we
can do that when america people go for
being have and say stop this environment
for our people and for your father
you don't be thank you and god bless you
and god bless america
anything to respond to the call he sees
the embargo is causing a great deal of
suffering yeah because of what people
think there you know but at the same
time there is a cuban regime who is
opposed to the the interchange
of medicines and information and culture
you see
the embargo doesn't contemplate the
exchange of medicine it doesn't so why
is that happening there why from spain
wheats and medicines in chips and the
medicines are sold in the in the store
for tourists or send away to help
whatever maybe
this situation now in central america
anything that gets there is not
distributed among the cuban people and
that's not the kill the the american
skills ability is the cuban regime who
does does to people what do you think
about the american policy of continuing
the embargo is it helpful to the goals i
don't think so but you invented that in
virgo and it had become the great
protects fidel has
so now i'm wondering myself how you will
manage to
release that embargo because he won't
allow you to do that that's the big
pretext he has as you saw this man
talking now with social emotional
uh
in such an emotional way he deeply
believes that the situation with his
relative is caused by the embargo so it
is in fidel castro's interest that the
embargo continues because he has an
enemy of course
we have about two minutes left with
elena fernandez she's going to be
speaking here at the miami book fair
international at about six is that right
this time you're on the schedule so if
you live in the area and would like to
listen in there's still an opportunity
to do that we have two more events later
on today with authors altogether nine
hours of live programming on this sunday
the 22nd of november from book tv next
telephone call is from columbus ohio
uh hi elena thanks for taking my call
there
uh just curious as to whether you feel
you have the ability to
speak freely about your father
as another every cuban as another normal
cuban you know i see him as a cuban
dictator that's why i'm an exiled woman
now
but he asked whether or not you can
comfortably speak freely without any
concerns
i do i can yes you mentioned earlier
that you're glad that this book has been
published in english
explain why how will you be going out to
talk about it what do you hope to
accomplish
as i told you at the beginning if you
can help communication between people
and people to understand what's going on
down there because the only thing you
hear is propaganda
that the embargoes writer is wrong that
the american policies this or that and
you have to realize that everything in
policy throws the united states come
from cuba that's why i'm showing in
every situation what's going on down
there
but the book begins when i was sitting
in my rocking chair with my pacifier and
i saw the revolution began so it's for
the year of given history i hope would
you tell us the story of your shoes
oh that there was no shoes yes that
happened
well from the beginning we are living in
a ration book so we eat and we dress
over that little book who allows some
amount of food monthly and it it's not
happening now under the blockade it had
happened in 1960 and from then to now
it's getting worse
so when i was 11 there was no book size
for me so i kept my
my feet in the same size shoes for two
years it had happened to all my
generation you you described it as being
like a young
chinese
woman of another generation yes feet too
large into small shoes
is it mandatory to serve in the military
for young people um yes both men and
women no no woman no women can turn why
is that
i don't know
uh i was afraid always they would invent
that for women too
tell me where you're the fate of your
mother where is she is she still she's
she's still there and she's still in
cuba
do you have any communication with her
of course are you close
not that close no
and uh what about your own relationship
with your daughter because you were
separated for many years i am no not for
many years she left the country she was
allowed to leave she was released
ten days later
and she's here
and why would they let her go then
i think that thanks to the media
pressure yes how did that play out what
happened
you left there was a great deal of
coverage and they allowed that's it i
think that that's the whole thing i i
tried to manage to get in touch with a
cuban ambassador
just to tell him that i was very quiet
and disposed not to speak about anything
if they released my daughter i never had
an answer so i went
on tv
and
again i'm going to show you because our
time is up i'm going to show you what
this book looks like in both versions
alina fernandez is the author and the
spanish version is here
and for those of you who are english
speakers it is called castro's daughter
it has been published by saint martin's
press just last month helena fernandez
here at the miami book fair
international to speak to the fairgoers
and also to spend some time with us
thank you for coming to tell us your
story
we next will show you one of the author
events that happened yesterday carl
heisen is a columnist with the miami
herald also the author of several books
and we taped one of his discussions with
the book fair goers and we'll show you a
portion of that next
okay this question is for carl my name
is francisco and i'm i'm from cuba i'm
here with